bloviating hairdo Jim Acosta has been
banned from the White House at least
temporarily after refusing to shut up
and playing keep-away with a female
White House intern then Democrats
advocate for segregated campuses but
nothing new there and leftist thugs try
to kick in Tucker Carlson's door in the
middle of the night an awful shooting
occurs in California but the political
activists are already out in force
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the star of CNN Jim Acosta has had his
White House press badge revoked for
reaction now we turn to Jim Acosta Jim
what can you tell us about having the
press pass revoked I'm Ron Burgundy
really strong really interesting we'll
have to get to more of that in just one
second but first let's make a little
money with expressvpn with all of the
recent news about online security
breaches it's hard not to worry about
where your data goes when you make an
online purchase or even if you just
access your email that could put your
private information at risk you are
being tracked online by social media
sites marketing companies and your
mobile or internet provider that's why I
decided to take back my privacy using
expressvpn you would be crazy not to use
a VPN right now everybody is stealing
your data foreign governments
corporations any time you were on the
internet your dad is at risk it's insane
not to expressvpn secures and anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public IP
address protect yourself with expressvpn
it costs less than seven bucks a month
seven bucks a month that is like a
medium-price latte do not just think
about what you've got on the internet
just think about what you're looking at
what you've got in your email what the
financial information protect it for
less than seven bucks a month find out
how you can get three months free to
express VPN calm slash michael mi CH AE
l that is e ex PR e SS VPN comm /
michael mi CH AE l for three months
three with a one-year package visit
expressvpn accom slash michael to learn
more this was jim Acosta's favourite day
it was his favorite day probably of his
entire life he gave us a little bit of
reaction he explained even more what
happened after the scuffle with a White
House intern and contacting the
president with a bunch of questions
he gets his pass revoked here's what he
says to Anderson Cooper yeah I went back
to the White House actually do a live
shot for your program just before 8
o'clock and when I arrived at the gate
the Secret Service came out and informed
me that my press credentials were being
I guess revoked temporarily suspended
and the Secret Service officer came over
to me and
me to hand over my credential and I did
and I told him I said listen I know
you're a professional you're just doing
your job and thanks for your service and
it a my credential I've had for five
years I want to read reaction from a few
colleagues covering the White House Jeff
Mason from Reuters has tweeted I was
seated next to a constant today's press
conference and did not witness him
placing his hands as in quotes on the
young intern as the White House alleges
he held onto the microphone as she
reached for him so that's what they're
saying that's what this is all about
that allegedly Jim Acosta pushed this
girl this White House intern who was
trying to take the mic away just pause
and take a moment and realize how much
Jim Acosta loves this how this is what
his entire career of being a journalist
his bill toward is going on CNN saying
I'm here they took away my White House
press badge me little old me i me my all
through the night I me my I me my I me
my he is loving every second of this
it's all about Jim being in the
spotlight and this is the story this is
actually why it's right for the White
House to revoke his press credential
it's not because he played keep-away
with this reporter some people right now
are trying to say that he physically
assaulted this reporter he didn't he did
get physical though he did he didn't go
in beat her she's not gonna have a
bruise but he did you know he didn't he
did get physical in the moment what he
really did is play keep-away for with
the reporter and that this is the big
problem is that Jim Acosta was there he
asked all of these questions Trump
answered the questions he kept asking
more he kept making more accusations and
he wouldn't give up the microphone think
about all these reporters in the room
who could have asked questions if Jim
Acosta had not been stealing the
spotlight for himself and then it's all
designed to create this polarity between
Jim Acosta and the White House and then
it's all about Jim Acosta one of the
things they tell you when you're trying
to be a real journalist is not to make
yourself the story you the reporter are
not supposed to be the story the story
is the story in your covering and Jim
Acosta doesn't do that Jim Acosta takes
every single chance he possibly can to
make himself the story
that's why his press credentials
be taken away because nobody benefits
from this nobody benefits from Jim
Acosta going out in making a star of
himself that's what we should be
covering the president we should be
covering the White House not covering a
bloviating hairdo so the question is did
he put his hands on the woman did he
actually assault her you can take a look
at the clip right now and judge for
yourself president asked one of the
other folks that said enough pardon me
ma'am
mr. president that's enough pardon me
ma'am pardon me keeps the microphone
away so if you couldn't see that it's a
it's a quick exchange we've slowed it
down in SuperDuper slow motion if you
can tolerate Jim Jim Acosta slow-motion
voice take a closer look pardon me ma'am
my beautiful hairdo is about to fall out
of shape ma'am no I need more gel and a
mousse in that so that's what's
happening those of you who are listening
to it and what happens is he's holding a
microphone he has going on now for
several minutes monopolizing the time in
this room and so Trump says that's
enough
okay I've answered several of your
questions I'm not gonna we're not gonna
get in a tit-for-tat here and so the
White House intern this lovely young
woman comes up to take the microphone
and he pulls the microphone away and as
he pulls it away his other hand is there
and pushes down on her arm that's going
to reach for the microphone so the left
is saying well she went for him
physically and then the right is saying
he hit a woman he pushed her shoved a
woman he assaulted a woman that's not
the issue that isn't the issue she was
perfectly within her rights to take the
microphone away from this bloviator and
he just reacting like the bloviating
star seeker that he is pulls the
microphone away to try to keep it and as
he's doing that he pushes her arm that's
the problem he's not behaving like a
gentleman he's not behaving with any
dignity befitting his occupation the
whole argument for CNN right now is that
Donald Trump is this loud this bore this
Bulgarian but CNN they're the serious
people they're going to restore dignity
to the country they're going to
then this is dignity this is what
happens is you play keep-away with this
young White House intern after
monopolizing the White House press corps
is time after monopolizing the
president's time and preventing other
reporters from asking questions are you
kidding me that's why his press pad
should be taken away it's it should be
taken away because he's getting exactly
what he wants right now and what he
wants is not to cover the prayer not to
cover the White House it's not to cover
the president it's not to cover national
policy it's to make himself famous and
go on air with Anderson Cooper and
pretend to be a super serious person I'm
speaking I'm actually sort of defending
Jim Acosta here in that I don't think
he's a woman-beater
assailant or something like that I think
that he is a narcissist and I have a
little bit of insight into this because
I knew Jim Acosta before Jim Acosta was
Jim Acosta actually when I was up at in
college I was working on a campaign to
try to get mitch Daniels to run for
president the Indiana governor and the
campaign got big enough that CNN sent
their young reporter Jim Acosta to cover
us here is a younger Jim Acosta and a
younger me it might be a stretch to call
him the big man on campus but Indiana
governor mitch Daniels is getting some
presidential buzz at colleges across the
country thanks to Yale University
students max Eden and Michael Knowles so
we the thing goes on and I an afternoon
with Jim Acosta and I left that thinking
because we were told watch out you're
doing a right-wing campaign at CNN's
coming up they're gonna cover you poorly
and so I assumed they were gonna be
really critical of the campaign and
really left-wing it wasn't that I don't
think Jim Acosta is really left-wing at
all I don't think he's left-wing I don't
think he's right-wing I think he's just
all about Jim Acosta and so the reaction
to this everyone's focusing on the
disrespect these showed to the woman
think about the disrespect to his
colleagues to the President of the
United States to the White House that's
really the disrespect here this is not
how gentlemen behave this is not how
journalists are supposed to behave and
if if they want to pretend in the
mainstream media that they are restoring
the dignity
of of that office even if President
Trump is allegedly degrading the dignity
then then they've got to put up or shut
up and they shouldn't have showboaters
out there so it's very fun and by the
way I mentioned this on the show the
other day the Trump gives everybody
everything that they want the high civic
engagement high voter turnout unifies
the Dems unifies the Republicans
protects American labor and industries
also gets foreign foreign adversaries to
lower their trade barriers and lower
their tariffs everybody gets what they
want Jim Acosta gets what he wants to he
gets to look super serious and become
the story again but how much longer are
we gonna tolerate this guy becoming the
story
speaking of actual threats to
journalists not fake threats like a
90-pound White House female intern and
the president making fun of Jim Acosta
Tucker Carlson has been attacked at his
home
Tucker Carlson fortunately he wasn't
home at the time but there was a major
left-wing attack and it tells you
everything you need to know about them
by what they were chanting how his wife
had to hide in fear in the pantry as
they tried to bust in before that
speaking of entering people's boudoirs
let's talk about purple mattress I love
purple mattress you know that I
proselytize purple mattress if you're
struggling to get a good night's sleep
you've got to try it I naturally have
back pain it runs in the family I've
tried a lot of different mattresses
purple is completely unlike any other
mattress it's not like an innerspring
it's not like the memory foam it's this
new technology it's unbelievable it was
developed by an actual rocket scientist
it's very unique because it's both it's
a totally unique mattress in that it's
both firm and soft at the same time it
keeps everything supported but it I know
that sounds crazy that's both firm and
soft it is somehow it really is it
sleeps very cool
it feels zero-gravity this morning I
woke up early to go do a news hit at
3:00 in the morning or something by the
time I came back I kid you not the first
thing I said to sweet little Elise as I
got back in bed I'm dead bone tired I
said ah I love our purple mattress I
love it so much load me right back to
sleep
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return it
for a full refund back by 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns
here's how you get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress these
things are expensive so the purple
pillows and you can get
for free with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide text
cough FAC of VF e EF e - 47 47 47 only
way to get the free pillow Texico FF a
co VF e fe - 47 47 47 co VF e fe - 47 47
47 and get a free super cool sweet
pillow love purple so well Tucker
Carlson's family was trying to rest in
at night and their home hopefully on
their purple mattress this screeching
mob of auntie Fah left-wingers attacked
his house let me be clear I'm not saying
that they went into his neighborhood or
they chased him out of a restaurant they
went to his house they cracked his front
door because they tried to bust in these
sick thugs tried to bust into his house
Tucker wasn't even home at the time his
wife was home of making dinner and she
heard then she assumed it was a home
invasion so she had to lock herself in
her pantry and fear for her life Tex
Tucker call 9-1-1 because these sick
left-wing thugs were trying to bust in
here's some video of them
[Music]
what a bunch of pathetic
little sad womanish and not womanly
woman ish unmanly hysterical children
thugs how pathetic I wonder what sort of
relationship these these little man
children have with their fathers
probably not great I would guess I think
all of these auntie feh all of the
screeching left wingers in the street
whatever they're chanting I think the
subtext is fu Dada fu Dada I'm not you
can't make me no that's what I think the
subtext is I think these are
psychologically very damaged people who
have glommed on to a sick perverse
political ideology to fill the gaping
long hole in their hearts because of the
sick shame that they feel when they gaze
at themselves in the mirror this shame
that their parents must feel to have
raised such horrible failures of
children like these what shame which
shame they've brought on their families
with whom I suspect they don't have a
very good relationship anyway awful
awful stuff I bring this up for a couple
of reasons one because of what they're
chanting we know that the left has been
encouraging violent attacks on prominent
right-wingers we know that that's been
happening for a long time but what
they're chanting they're saying we know
where you sleep at night that's pretty
sick stuff but then one of the other
chants they said was no borders no wall
no USA at all that's what you're dealing
with
you're dealing with people who are
openly calling for the destruction of
the United States this is the same group
in DC by the way called smash racism DC
which chased Ted Cruz out of that
restaurant so they're calling for the
abolition of the United States a lot of
these videos now disappeared from social
media because obviously they're quite
violent now what the left is saying in
response is they're saying that there
are right-wing extremists - what about
that guy who sent the mail bombs none of
which went off a couple weeks ago what
about him see people on both sides okay
so what you're pointing to is one
homeless stripper with a make America
great again hat who failed to commit
violent acts against left wingers who
failed 100% to commit violent acts
against
winger's okay yeah bad guy the entire
right unified and condemned that guy now
what the right is pointing to are these
mobs of violent wackos who were busting
down Tucker Carlson's door who were
attacking Ted Cruz in public attacking
Mitch McConnell in public and how are
the mainstream left wingers reacting
they're encouraging the right condemns
their lunatics
the left encourages it political
commentators mainstream ones and elected
officials are like Maxine Waters Eric
Holder Hillary Clinton and just to look
at the Talking Heads
I often recommend that people read
voxcom that left-wing website insane
left-wing hack website but it's good to
read it to figure out what the left is
thinking I encourage people to go read
that a writer at voxcom
a matthew Yglesias this is how he
responded to this attack on Tucker
Carlson's family quote I think the idea
behind terrorizing his family like it or
not as a strategy is to make them feel
some of the fear that the victims of
Magha inspired violence feel thanks to
the nonstop racial incitement coming
from Tucker Trump etc the victims Tucker
Carlson's victim the victims of what the
victims of tweets the victims of
enforcing our laws the victims of having
a border at all is that what you're
saying so he's defending these thugs
this is a very prominent left-wing
commentator at perhaps the most
prominent left-wing on my media outlet
defending it he then goes on because
that wasn't enough to defend them he
says I honestly cannot empathize with
Tucker Carlson's wife at all with his
wife at all I agree that protesting at
her house was tactically unwise and
shouldn't be done but I'm utterly unable
to identify with her plight on any level
right because you're a child because
you're a little whiny child
I wonder what relationship you have to
your family to speaking of you because
you're lumping yourself in Matthew
Iglesias with all of these sick little
children who are trying to commit
violence against an innocent woman for
the crime of being married to a
television talk show host
six stuff really really sick stuff and
he is defending so don't ever let them
tell you that there's a moral
equivalence between the left and the
right oh yeah there's a Trump fan who
sent a pipe bomb and there are left
wingers who attack people's houses it's
all the same no the entire right
condemned the the pipe bomb homeless
stripper Donald Trump came out and said
he should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law but when the left does
it they are encouraged by elected
officials and by these news media
outlets he goes on I mean you but
Matthew Iglesias went on this crazy
Twitter rant today said I met a woman
who didn't leave the house for months
because she was afraid of being picked
up by ice and never seeing her US
citizen kids and husband again what
sense was there in terrorizing her
family she's in violation of the laws
she's a foreign national we have laws
for a reason we have a border we have to
be able to decide who comes into the
country who doesn't come into the
country what he actually said is I met a
criminal who didn't go out very much
because she didn't want the cops to
catch her for her crime okay yeah I'm
it's too bad that she committed a crime
she shouldn't have done it but we have
to have a border because when you don't
have a border you incentivize horrible
things like 60 to 80 percent of young
women and girls across the border
illegally being raped or sexually
assaulted according to The Huffington
Post infusion and Amnesty International
like human traffickers bringing drugs
and children across the border to do
nefarious things with them like unvetted
people like the national security risk
that opposes like the fact that every
other country on Earth gets to determine
who enters and who leaves the country
Mexico gets to Guatemala gets to
Honduras gets to Nicaragua gets to but
the United States not allowed to okay
absurd absurd common and true moral
idiocy from this guy you know last night
I was at this event at Loyola Marymount
with Drew we did a joint speech and at
this speech a race became a big issue
there was a an exclusively black student
group who came and they were protesting
and they were very angry and this really
reminded me of some of the insanity
that's going on right now at the college
campuses at Ohio University right now
there is a proposal to have a minorities
only Jim
a gym that can only be used by racial
minorities now I assume that the campus
administrators are going to tell us that
the gym has this equal facilities to the
gym for white people it's just separate
you might call the gym
I don't know the separate-but-equal gym
that's me you have Democrats advocating
for racial segregation because there is
nothing new Under the Sun blue sash on
Bruce lmm shows nothing changes ever and
this is going on across the country
there is a self segregation that is
going on there is an insistence by
minority students that we return to the
days of racial segregation there are a
couple reasons for this one reason is
that they don't know anything they don't
know anything about history they don't
know anything about politics they don't
know about the American Founding and
they don't know about the real state of
politics in America the other reason is
that victimhood carries a currency today
it carries a real currency there is a
social status associated with victimhood
obviously you can look at a at one
particular example of affirmative action
and say that victimhood carries
advantages because if you can show that
your race or your sex or whatever has
been historically oppressed in the
United States then you gain an advantage
in college admissions but it also
carries a social advantage beyond that
at this event at Loyola Marymount there
was this group of exclusively black
students and they came in and they had
duct tape on their mouths and they were
protesting what they were protesting I
don't know the suggestion seemed to be
that they were being censored and so
they were gonna protest that but of
course they weren't being censored they
put the duct tape on their own mouths so
drew and I confronted them to show the
hollowness of this victim ideology here
it is all right this will be our last
question of the evening well you know
before we go I should point out there
are people in the back of the room who
have put tape over their mouths as
though they've been censored as though
they're not able to speak so I just like
to take the opportunity nobody is
stopping you from speaking nobody is
we're actually inviting you to speak if
anybody would like to come up and ask a
question now is your opportunity you can
cut the entire line would anybody who
has a masking tape over their mouths
well you don't
masking tape you can come ask a question
too but I I mean specifically the people
who are making a statement and saying I
am being censored would any of you like
to remove the masking tape which you put
on yourself and come up here and ask a
question or would you rather stand back
there and play the victim I think we got
my answer okay
next guy line let's hear like he's gonna
wait how did I know that that was gonna
happen they stand there for those of you
who couldn't see they're standing there
with the team they're just staring and
they're staring looking if they look
slack-jawed if they didn't have tape on
their mouths holding their mouth up
because the point that they're trying to
make is totally empty but it is a
wonderful reflection of race hustling
and race politics in America because
they put the tape on their mouths
themselves they did it themselves they
did it because there's a currency to
being a victim and when you call them
out for it and when you say you're not a
victim you're not a victim at all you're
here you can speak use that beautiful
hand that God gave you to take the tape
off your own mouth the tape that you put
on yourself and speak use your voice
use your political speech use the thing
the very thing that makes us human the
ability to have meaningful speech use it
and we'll engage and we can talk they
can't do it cuz they have nothing to say
nothing to say other than insinuation
and race hustling nonsense to suggest
the suggestion on their signs that they
were holding up is that a drew and I or
racist I don't know where they got that
from I don't know what their evidence is
that Drew and I were somehow preventing
them from speaking so I wanted to point
out that nobody's preventing them from
speaking but nobody is the Candis Owen
started this walk away campaign and now
she's calling it blech Syd I think the
black exit from the Democrat Party
because for so long black voters have
voted 90% with Democrats between mid 80s
and low 90s percent with Democrats and
it's bizarre that a race would vote so
uniformly with one political party you
don't see this with other races and
she's saying you can walk away you're
being sold a bill of goods and what
they're being told is that the
Republican Party is racist conservatives
are racist they hate you they don't like
you they don't want you they want to
hurt you
that whatever whatever and sick lies
that they're being told by race hustlers
and so they've gone along with this
nobody is trying to stop you nobody's
trying to stop you from speaking freedom
is a wonderful thing opening up your
mouth and using your political speech
and engaging with people who with whom
you think you disagree even though I
suspect you probably don't disagree on
very much but you don't know that
because you're so interested in looking
at yourself in preening and making
yourself into a victim that you won't
actually engage and open your mouth and
talk to your your fellow Americans
really sad really pathetic that
university has clearly failed them and
their families have failed them too
there's a theme I think growing today
among the people were looking at on the
left and this is a theme broadly that as
social structures have collapsed as
family structures has collapsed
local communities have collapsed people
are really falling into political idiocy
and political extremism on the left and
it's a sad state of affairs and it's
being encouraged by by elected officials
you know now the guy who was running for
governor of Florida
Andrew Gilliam he's a socialist race
hustler who baselessly accused
Republican Ron De Santis of being a
racist absolutely no grounding for that
whatsoever he conceded because he got
beaten by the Santas and then he
unconsidered because because Democrats
can never concede an election they just
need to dig up a few more dead votes and
then though they'll be able to put him
over the top
so he's unconceived Stacey Abrams who is
running in Georgia for governor of
Georgia she has unconsidered or I don't
maybe she didn't concede in the first
place even though she got beat so Bernie
Sanders has come out now and he is
blaming racism for not electing Stacey
Abrams was black and Andrew Gilliam
who's black blaming racism that's all
they've got that's the only thing that
they can say and it's meaningless and I
highly recommend it was a cathartic
moment last night when you go out and
you say here's your opportunity tell me
everything you want to tell me they
won't say anything because there's
nothing to it there's nothing to the
charge at all it's just sick race
hustling and it's the sign of a
desperate Democrat party
you know one of the great aspects of the
midterms is that in those key races that
the Democrat candidates whom the party
really wanted to propel really wanted to
make into stores they
Aled Beto O'Rourke got beaten Beto or
ork Stacey Abrams Andrew Gilliam was
being talked about as a possible
Democrat presidential nominee they all
got beat and as a result now there's
there was a poll that Hill TV took it
was the hill TV American barometer poll
680 Democrat voters so a relatively
small sample size nevertheless who do
you think came up first we know all the
people we've talked about is possible
2020 candidates Joe Biden laia Wafaa
Cory Booker Hillery still being talked
about the readthe defied corpse of
Hillary Clinton marching on to her 75th
try at the White House so joe biden got
168 votes he came in second Bernie
Sanders got 123 came in third
Hillary somehow found 80 votes Kamala
Harris 28 votes Mike Bloomberg 27 votes
do you know who came in first none of
the above none of the above won the
Democrat preference poll and this is
especially true among younger voters so
four for older voters they still
selected none of the above
but that the percentage increased among
younger voters and which is obviously
the case
nobody wants Hillary Clinton to be
President though they might nominate her
anyway
all of these desiccated old corrupt
crony Democrats all they've got is
they're running on resentment they're
running on racism and sexism and all
that sick hustling they've got no issues
to back them up and Democrats want a
different choice I'm not surprised but
there are future stores just got beaten
there at Michael avenatti is probably
gonna start wearing an orange jumpsuit
pretty soon as he's been referred for
criminal investigation by the Senate
Judiciary Committee
they've got nobody they've got nothing
they're running on empty that's why they
run on racism and it's really sad we
should speak for just a second about the
shooting in Thousand Oaks this morning
this shooting happened very early in the
morning it was a massive shooting 12
people are dead so far also the gunman
is dead and a lot of people are injured
up there this was in a country music bar
country music dance bar this guy comes
in and just starts shooting it turns out
he's a Marine Corps
any served in Afghanistan and already of
course the gun control activists arrived
this was trending on Twitter with him an
hour I think of the shooting this
obviously prayers to the victims and
their families from the political angle
reacting to the political activists who
are already trying to push for gun
control this is an interesting case
because it's an ex-military guy who
committed the murders so this is a guy
who was well trained with weapons who
had security clearances who read
background checks at least who knew how
to use a gun
who by any measure when we're talking
about gun control we say that law
enforcement and ex-military should be
able to have guns he had he had his guns
he purchased the guns legally the gun
was not an ar-15 they always try to on
the left say that ar-15s need to be
banned and this will stop the problem
even though virtually nobody is killed
every year from ar-15s the vast vast
majority of people killed in gun
incidents those incidents involved
handguns this guy used a handgun as well
so none of the boxes that they would
typically be pushing effort gun control
would qualify in this case however there
is one aspect which is not gun control
which might have helped prevent this
shooting which is that in recent years
deputies have interacted with this guy
for domestic disturbances actually a
sheriff's deputy was one of the victims
one of the people he went in he was
first on the scene he he went in there
to try to stop him
unfortunately he was killed deputies
have interacted with this killer in
recent years for domestic disturbances
and they came in and they realized he
was almost certainly suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder
he served in Afghanistan a lot of
soldiers come back with PTSD it seemed
like he was suffering from it they
couldn't do anything about it it
couldn't do anything about it because
they couldn't involuntarily commit him
it's virtually impossible to
involuntarily commit people to mental
institutions today and that's been the
case for decades and decades because
they couldn't do that because they
couldn't throw him in a loony bin to
protect the public from him twelve
people are dead today there is no gun
law that they could have passed
short of confiscation and even then even
then there are 300 million guns in the
country criminals will get their hands
on guns there's no gun law that they
could have passed to prevent this
shooting but if you've made it easier
I've been saying this every time there's
a mass shooting if you made it easier to
involuntarily commit insane people who
are a danger to themselves and to others
you at you could have prevented this
shooting that's the one thing you could
have done that would have prevented it
but very few people are talking about it
because it's it doesn't serve people's
political agendas especially on the left
and because it's a very difficult thing
to say that we need to use the fourth
force of the state to be able to commit
insane people who pose a danger it's a
tough thing the right doesn't like it
the left doesn't like it nevertheless
it's true okay we've got to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube we got a lot of
mailbag coming up if you're not on daily
wire.com that means you're on social
media but you probably won't be for long
cuz she'll probably get censored go to
daily wire it's ten bucks a month 100
hours for an annual membership you get
me you get the Andrew Clavin sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you test
questions in the mailbag get test
questions in the conversation I think
I'm coming up on that next by the way
you also get the most important thing in
the world which is early access to
another Kingdom you get to watch another
Kingdom on Mondays other people who are
not subscribers have to wait years and
years and years or at least until Friday
to get the audio you'll get to see the
whole thing with all of that artwork and
oh yes there it is
the leftist tears tumblr you get the
leftist tears tumblr I wish that I'd
brought some of these last night to
loyola marymount so that i could have
used them to swim my way off of the
campus you need yours as well it's the
only fda-approved device to handle salty
radioactive delicious leftist tears go
to daily wire.com we'll be right back
with the mailbag
we're gonna get through them all today
probably not but we'll try from Jerry in
all of entertainment what industry that
is music film TV theater or fiction etc
do you think would have the best
cultural impact if it became more
politically balanced music the music
industry that's the one and it's not
even about political balance it's
actually a little bigger than political
balance it has to become less tribal and
passionate this is true of pop music
it's true a rap it's true dubstep EDM
whatever it's if it became more
sophisticated our politics would improve
greatly look it would be good if we had
movies about how great Ronald Reagan is
it would be good if we had TV shows that
describe the world as it is rather than
some leftist fantasy but music is the
most important of the art forms the
ancient Greeks talked about this Plato
talked about this and hearing is the
most important sense in throughout the
Bible you always hear the Word of God
God speaks to you you hear the voice of
God Christ is the word is the word made
flesh you hear the voice of God and it's
because to hear things
it goes cuts right through the soul and
this is true when you listen to music
when you are in your car and you're
listening to hide in your Brahms or
something and you're a dude to do you're
driving down the road listening to Bach
and there do dododo dododo then you get
out of your car you feel a certain way
your head is in a more rational place if
you're in your car and you're just
blasting EDM I do you're gonna get out
of your car feeling more like an animal
you're gonna feel like a brute for lack
of a better word because percussive
tribal brutal music
dedenne's your rational faculties and
incites the base passions I don't have
to say that more politically incorrectly
than that but the ancient Greeks knew
what they were talking about and this
has been true throughout the history of
Western music specifically percussion
really arouses passions that are at odds
with your rational faculties so if we
were able to get into
and I'm not saying we need to play the
The Magus song or something start to get
pop music to use more conservative words
I'm saying that the music itself should
be more conservative I think it would
really tamp down passions because also
that's the art form we interact with the
most we hear it in coffee shops we're
playing it on our iPods we're playing it
when we're in the car where we listen to
it at bars and clubs
we are constantly interacting with music
if music were better and more
sophisticated our culture would be
better and more sophisticated too from
Peter mr. Noles
I recently subscribed but now face a
dilemma I have a wonderful girlfriend
who wants my leftist tears tumblr I
can't say no as I'm lucky enough to have
found a conservative girlfriend could
you find it in your charitable Catholic
heart to intercede on my behalf and ask
Ben if I can get a second tumbler
absolutely not you sick monster you
hedonistic entitled millennial how you
hit the gold mine you so you're a
subscriber you've been able to use the
leftist tears tumblr the only FDA
approved device to safely dispose of
leftist yours you're you're getting
along and then you meet a beautiful
wonderful conservative girlfriend and
she wants your tumblr and you get the
you have the honor of giving to your
lady your tumblr and then you have the
temerity to ask for another one that's
not how it works in this life bucko
count your blessings you have a
wonderful woman on your arm you've got
at least one leftist here's tumblr that
you two can share that you can come
together as one flesh and guzzle leftist
tears and you want another one talk
about talk about modernity talk about
just never knowing when you've got
enough you should you should think long
and hard about your life and can stop
and count your blessings from Margo hi
definitely not Michael Knowles why is it
that lefties tend to degenerate and use
profanity
it seems that conservatives tend to use
more polite and eloquent language what's
the point of the profanity it's see it's
not appealing and makes me think even
less of them cheers and cough FA they
speak in a profane vole
in coherent way because their thoughts
are profane and vulgar and incoherent
they can't state what they believe they
don't have a coherent view of the world
and so they have to pepper their spasms
of speech with profanities they do this
because they're not confident in what
they believe and they they're trying too
hard they're pushing they think that if
they say the f-word then you'll take
them seriously that's the pod save
America guys they don't really say
anything they say it's so effing
important I'm a serious person that's
why they do it now there are uses of
profanity there are plenty of uses of
profanity but not the way that they use
it because they use it in this whiny
emotional earnest way really swearing
you know swearing in the sense that
they're making a swear they're making an
oath they're cursing you they're
literally cursing their opponents when
they do it you can use profanity in a
way that's funny you know when you're
hanging out with the guys and you've got
a good joke and then you use profanity
to make that joke funnier that's a very
different use of profanity you're not
doing it out of anger you're not doing
it to hurt or curse or swear you're
doing it to liven up the conversation
and make it funny this is why guys will
use profanity when they're around each
other but they'll use it a little less
when they're around women traditionally
they don't use it around women at all
and now in culture it's much more common
to do that but it's a it's because it is
foul it is disgusting
it's not fit for public use so I was on
a panel about comedy and someone asked
me if I would swear or I was on a
remembers a podcast or something they
said or are you gonna start using a lot
of profanity and I said no I won't I'll
do that if I'm at a bar with the guys
but I'm not gonna do it if I'm in public
on a public platform there's a time and
a place for everything but the left
doesn't know about appropriate
situations and the right times and
places they want to behave like
hedonists and little children all the
time everywhere and and that's why we
think less of them that's why you think
less of them from our own dear dr. koh
FFA what are your thoughts on marijuana
use
I drank beer in college I liked it a lot
and still do reminds me of a Supreme
Court justice I like but I've never used
marijuana and have a gut feeling that
it's immoral that said I cannot
justify this feeling philosophically or
alcohol and marijuana fundamentally
different moral entities I'm curious
about your opinion at a secular level
and in terms of your Catholic faith
alcohol and marijuana are fundamentally
different entities at a physical level
as at the level of drugs they're they're
different I have smoked pot I've smoked
pot before in you know college or
whenever and I don't really like it so I
think I actually have a pretty good take
on this because I've I've definitely
tried it I've used it but I've never
like wanted it I've never put it you
know I've never had some in my house so
that I could have it alone as if someone
has offered it in college or something
I've tried it I don't like it one
because it makes you stupid or into
because it makes you less funny and it
makes you really inward and really
introspective and alcohol does the
opposite alcohol relaxes your a little
bit and then it's a social lubricant and
can liven up a party and so I don't know
whether it's immoral to use marijuana I
mean it's it's immoral to become
belligerently drunk or intoxicated and
in so much is getting really high does
that then I suppose that's immoral but
it's really just a question of why are
you using the drug you know I know
plenty of people who use who drink
alcohol socially virtually everyone does
that eighty percent of the people I know
who smoke pot or huge pot heads and they
wake and bake and they can just use it
all the time so that suggests
something's wrong with that it's also
foreign it's a it's foreign to our
culture alcohol has been around forever
the first miracle that Christ performs
is turning wine into or water into wine
for drunk people at a wedding and so
it's been around for a very long time
and we we know how to use it in social
situations pot is now being introduced
for the first time on a broad level to
the culture and the question is if these
things can be abused why would you
introduce a new one why would you add
that to your repertoire look at the kind
of people who drink and the kind of
situations in which people drink do you
like those people or you do you like
being in those situations and maybe it's
okay to have a drink look at the
situations in which people are smoking
pot and the kind of people who are
obsessed with pot and legalization
if you
want to be like them if you want to be
in those situations go for it but I
suspect you probably don't from Adam
why do Democratic voters overlook the
corruption of politicians like Hillary
or Andrew Gilliam thanks Adam from
Florida oh because they have no
standards they have no standards at all
they don't care for them the personal is
the political they're in an all-out
blood war with conservatives they treat
politics as religion and so they don't
care if somebody is totally corrupt and
hollowed out on the inside as long as
they can be effective they'll go for
them they'll they'll overlook it because
they they are all about the revolution
the perpetual revolution what Stalin
either apocryphally or actually said
that it you know Stalin and many other
people you know they say one death is a
tragedy ten deaths is a tragedy a
million deaths is a statistic you've
heard communists for a long time say
you've got to crack a few eggs to make
an omelet they're perfectly fine dealing
in things that are fundamentally wrong
and immoral because they think it's
gonna lead them to paradise that it's
gonna lead them to utopia and to
progress this is the lie that the
serpent told Eve in the garden Oh
just break this one little rule and then
then things will be really really great
and it turns out that when you break
those little rules you breed a lot of
misery for everybody from Sarah hey
Michael since you were kicked off
Twitter I decided to finally subscribe
my question is when you have kids do you
plan to take them with you to vote and
how important do you think this is I
have three kids and they all go vote
with me and they love it absolutely I
will I came in with my mother when I was
nine yeah it was six years old to force
her to vote for Bob Dole she kind of
likes Bill Clinton I loved Bob Dole I
was the only guy in the country who
really wanted Bob Dole to be President
probably including Bob Dole but I really
really liked him and my mother finally
relented we committed voter fraud
because I pulled the lever on behalf of
Bob Dole and it was terrific and it
really got me in thews II a stick about
voting and I highly encourage that for
your kids as well because something
tells me if you subscribe to this show
you're the kind of person that we should
have voting and you're raising kids that
we should have voting to so make sure
that we do it
Democrats make a business out of
coercing people into voting and we
should make sure that we get our our
people to vote - final question from
Laurel I think this is from Laurel who
paints all the pictures on the wonderful
artists on Twitter hello - my favorite
Catholic besides tal Keane several times
on your show you've talked about links
between witchcraft and feminism do you
know if the rise of the interest which
crack of the interest in witchcraft
could have anything to do with Harry
Potter of course we know it's a favorite
story of the left but do you also think
it could have a link with people act
actually practicing witchcraft Laurel I
don't think so I think the rise in the
popularity of Harry Potter has to do
with the illiteracy and shallowness of
our culture but the fact that our our
generation in particular is so
illiterate that the only myth they can
ever refer to is Harry Potter which is a
very mediocre series of children's
stories about going to boarding school
with a little witchcraft sprinkled on
top of it to make it a little bit spicy
I don't think so I think Harry is a
moral figure I read them or I read some
of them when I was a kid and Dumbledore
is clearly a moral figure so I really
don't think so this was a big debate I
think especially among Catholics at the
time as to whether this should be banned
because it promotes witchcraft I don't
think so it's a fantasy and I think the
people who now are practicing witchcraft
and who boast about practicing
witchcraft and try to put hexes on Brett
Kavanaugh I don't think it's because
they read Harry Potter as kids I think
it's because they're into way darker
stuff and there are way darker things in
our culture than a mediocre children's
book and the only thread I think that
mediocre children's book poses is for
many Millennials it was the last book
that they read it's the only book they
ever referenced but that isn't JK
Rowling's fault that's the fault of our
institutions of higher learning and
families which have not inculcated a
sense of reading and a desire to read
and know our culture into the generation
I'd like to blame J or JK Rowling for
tweeting crazy leftists things but but
the decline in culture and the rise of
witchcraft or not her fault okay that's
our show I am gonna be on the road I'm
gonna be on the road next week giving
some speeches all
the Midwest so stay tuned for that
that's gonna be a lot of fun but we're
still gonna have a lot of shows make
sure you tune in to another Kingdom and
get caught up because it's doing really
really well it's getting huge ratings
huge huge the biggest ratings folks okay
people are really liking it and it's
certainly gonna be my last job I ever
have as an actor in Hollywood so be sure
to check it out have a good weekend in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolan is produced by semia
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austen Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018